the important thing to understand about
this is if you make 10 bucks an hour
with inflation with this mass printing
of money we've effectively just lowered
the minimum wage
basically in terms of buying power of
course everybody's value is stripped
even the business owners
another way to look at it is let's say
you worked for 50 years
or you know what's yeah 40 40 some odd
years you finally retired
and you got a couple hundred grand in
your retirement account well you're not
going to make
more that's your money that's your
budget for the rest of your life
and then they mass print trillions of
dollars devaluing that currency also in
your retirement account
is worth half of what it was no longer
enough to actually retire on what do you
do
i guess a lot of people are going to
become dependent on the government to
keep printing money for them because the
money they have is no longer sound
enough to actually buy things
so then you get people who work at
walmart because walmart gets special
kickbacks from government
walmart then pays their employees trash
their employees then have to get
government benefits and
around and around but the government's
not even printing it it's the it's the
federal reserve a private company is
printing it for us so
and then we give them we give them notes
of like
we promise to give you the money back
right that's what these are
if we were to default on that and say
you know what federal reserve we can't
we're not what would happen
well the whole system breaks at that
point in time the whole world the whole
world breaks
the petrol dollar so so it's not just we
the people who who
are on the hook for those treasury notes
right so we owe a bunch of those to
china china holds
1.3 trillion dollars of them there's
about seven trillion dollars of u.s
obligations out there in the world it's
a big number a trillion is a big
number this is the crazy thing what that
really means and correct if i'm wrong
that china has guaranteed access to u.s
labor
right that's ultimately what the money
would get them something produced or
a service provided by an american
they're getting so it's effectively like
when the u.s borrows money from china to
pay back with interest
they're saying this cur that what we're
going to give you assures that the
people in our country will work for you
in some capacity is that the chinese
central bank that we owe
yes that that's who's nominating the
chinese version of the federal reserve
yeah the people's bank of china um and
then there's the bank of
uh well the the so are you familiar with
the bank of international settlements
the bank so that's like the the mother
central bank where all the other central
banks funnel their money through
um i would imagine that the bank of
china and the federal reserve
are connected through the bank for
international settlements
yeah and i don't know that it's useful
really to think about different
countries when you get to the banking
or cartels you know they're really a
tribe you know
they hang out together and i'm not
really clear what the difference is
between
all the member banks at the bis and
because i don't know that they have
sovereign interests
but is it really like how you just
explained they do things on paper to
make it seem like it's legitimate when
in reality they just control
whether you get access to resources or
not yeah so
um i give a lot of talks right and i've
been in front of
i'm guessing ten thousand different
audience members at this point time and
i always ask this one question
i say particularly u.s audiences i say
how many of you ever learned about how
money is created in the system
i watched zeitgeist i've had two hands
go up
that whole time like taught in school
right one was at a crazy marxist
professor at umass another was it
oberlin economics professor again a nut
but you can teach this to fifth graders
and i know because i have and once you
teach people how money is created in the
system
because this whole idea that the federal
reserve has money no they don't they
just literally click on a keyboard
and it's created in that moment it's
digital isn't it yes it's it's all
digital it's not even paper not even
that
like when you go and borrow money from a
bank people thinking like jimmy stewart
it's a wonderful life and you go down
and your savings are in my
mortgage it's not like that at all when
i go to a bank and i take out a mortgage
they click on keyboards again
and when i borrow say 400 000 to buy a
house they just that's when it got
created that's when the four hundred
thousand came into poof bm
now here's the easiest way to i break
down to people why it's a problem
because i i've got a bunch of these you
know lefty friends
who are like you know we need this two
thousand dollar stimulus bill and i'm
like i hear you i hear you you do i get
it i get it
you're gonna get evicted your job has
been taken away from you but i think the
real issue is that they've taken away
your ability to provide for yourself
so i try to explain to them why it's a
problem we're putting all this money and
i'll put it very simply
there's there's five of us here in this
room imagine
there was one dollar between the five of
us
and i'd give it to luke and then luke
would trade it to ian and ian would
trade it and that's how the economy
functioned
now imagine one day i show up and i
start drawing on a piece of paper
dollars i'm doing no work i'm trading
nothing for anybody
and i'm convincing all of you to give me
your stuff because i drew a picture
that's basically what's happening
we're all as the work as working people
doing something in exchange for a good
so that we can provide for each other
resources and then
the government basically comes in and
says oh i did work here's my money too
and we go oh thank you government but
they didn't they just drew it on a piece
of paper they typed it on the keyboard
and pressed enter
and we're giving away our stuff to
people who aren't working on our for us
or with us
or trading with us so we're using their
money pictures
and the payment for that is we got to
give them interest for it
and what what is interest in this story
do you think what what is that
percentage of the picture uh
one for every hundred so to me if you're
the bank and you loan me that 400 000
mortgage and i pay it back to you that
money was created and it's given back
but where did the interest come from in
this story what does that represent
well what it represents is my labor over
time so over the next 30 years if i have
a mortgage
i borrowed 400 i might pay 800 back
depending on the rate of interest
where did that 400 000 come from well it
came from my hard work but when you
created that 400 000 what'd you do you
went clickity click
click that was the total work yes in
that story
but me i'm doing 30 more years in a
garage and as a bus driver is or
whatever whatever right um
so that's this that's why it's never
taught in school
because once you learn that you go that
doesn't feel right
it's one big ponzi scheme with these
individuals providing absolutely no
value at all banking wall street they're
the only industry that literally
is the only people that don't actually
produce something of of a service
don't actually produce a good they just
literally make it out of thin air
that's that's that's absolutely wrong
luke you are wrong
they provide excellent source material
for movies like the wolf of wall street
okay that was a
great awesome it's awesome with matthew
mcconaughey and he's pounding on his
chest uh they used
that's awesome see if it wasn't for
these guys would we be entertained they
used to execute bankers for
charging interest they called it usually
it was a it was a capital punished
capital crime to commit usury which was
to charge interest on the loan
but you know i have a bad chance
honestly 1700's 1800s or something i
personally have no issue if i've got 10
bucks and i say okay i can front you the
money now but i want back eleven dollars
i mean if i'm actually giving you not
taking that risk giving a flat
interest rate is different than a
compounding interest rate say i want
i want that back plus ten percent is
different than saying plus one percent
every month until you pay me back
well look if i i think if someone enters
into a contract it's their choice
if i have money if i say look i'm going
to lend you this you know half bottle of
water but you got to give me a full
bottle of water when you know in a month
or so
i think i'm fine with that the problem
is when i'm like okay
um i'm not actually gonna give you any
real water i'm gonna spit in a bottle
call it water and then you gotta give me
a full body
full bottle of water back but even with
the spitting what you're doing there is
you're actually doing something right
even spitting his work
so you're doing something that's the
difference here and and so the idea of
like if i earn ten dollars because of my
hard labor and then i decide to loan 10
to luke and
and you know he's going to pay me back
11. that's a different story from saying
i'm going to create 10 out of thin air
and then insist that you give it all
back plus
some vig whatever the particularly
compounding interest right so
so that's the game and by the way that
game is going to unravel
in everybody's lifetime here mine yours
everybody this is this is the story
that's coming apart because it made a
lot of sense in a time when you could
just continue to grow exponentially
forever that's what we've been doing on
this planet
and our money system is no different
it's just compounding compounding
more and more and more debt now it's
kind of on that steep phase you know you
look at the pull up a chart of like
us government debt it is well i've
written yeah yeah i've got uh
st louis fed.org economic research money
stock have you seen this
yeah it just goes up and then look at
this in 2020 it goes from
you can see yeah beginning of the year
it just skyrockets
billions of dollars jumps from 4 000
to 7 000. so it's like 4 trillion to 7
trillion right
yeah but but that increase that's a 66
increase in 12 months so
all the money used in this country for
66 in one year
because the last time we talked about
was at 35 yeah that well
now they're printing more there's more
this is m1 you're looking at probably
which is which is demand
that's uh checking savings plus currency
right but think about that
every dollar created in our country was
about 800 billion
up until before the first great
financial crisis right every bridge
every war fought every school every
everything
took 800 billion of money saw creation
then they doubled that in about a year
and that's that model has just been
going and you can feel it's getting
faster and faster so for all your
listeners out there
just ask yourself is it does it feel
like it's just speeding up
yup because it actually is so uh so
bitcoin
i i mean those charts look similar to
the bitcoin charts uh
especially i have a i have a phone
with uh you know it has a bitcoin wallet
on it and it's an old phone so i just
was like at one point i was like
whatever you know just put it in a box
and it forgot about it
and then i i'm following max kaiser on
uh on twitter you guys know max you know
nick's right yep
orange pill podcast and he's he's got
this really funny meme
where he says have fun staying poor have
you seen that people
people who keep telling them bitcoin was
like don't buy bitcoin it's crazy
doesn't make sense
it's him sitting in a chair like looking
at the camera says have fun staying poor
and so i'm seeing him post these things
and then all of a sudden i'm like people
saying bitcoin broke it's all-time high
and i'm like where's that phone hitting
i'm like trying to figure out where it
is and it's dead and i got to plug it in
to see like what's still on it because
it's 28 000
for one coin couple years ago well this
is the thing
three thousand dollars people are
looking for alternatives to the dollar
people are looking to get out of this
thing that of course people are just
printing like crazy and that's why we're
seeing i think
in one instance why cryptocurrencies are
doing so well right now because of this
incredible amount of money let me let me
tell you
i i think crypto is not the right call i
think gold is not the right call if
there's one thing you got to buy it's
primal youth by dr
jones spinning infowars.com no no no no
no water access to water
watching that video of these people
storm through this supermarket
because of the lockdowns and they're
like we want food like we want to shop
you can have all the bitcoin in the
world when an angry mob is hungry
they're not going to stop to ask you for
your
for your private you know or for your
public key or whatever to do in exchange
they're gonna they're gonna punch in the
face and take your sandwich of course
that's why i bought ammo heirloom seeds
a lot of medicine that we can't even
mention on this show right now
uh you know being prepared and having
you know personal responsibility is the
absolute key and when you're paying
attention when you know
you know big companies like citadel and
blackrock and you see the revolving door
you see the game that's being played on
the american people
and you see the writing on the wall it's
there and it's becoming
way more and more evident and when the
people who are rioting are going to find
out about the exact details
i don't know oh boy i don't know what's
going to happen you guys see this video
out of new york where the kids are
smashing the suv
yeah throwing their bikes at one one kid
you know runs up jumps and then drop
kicks the windshield it was a medical
suv apparently new york is
look it's a way i'll i'm going to call
it a wasteland because i'm being
hyperbolic but let me tell you something
what people don't understand about
extreme circumstances that you're a frog
in a pot with the water level
the heat slowly rising until the water
boils and you don't realize it
think about what you were doing in new
york a couple years ago compared to what
you can do in new york now and you might
be like oh that's kind of crazy
can't do any of that anymore when was
the last time you saw a story about a
mob of people breaking into a
supermarket
new york city is it's you know their
street races at night now i'm seeing
these videos of people just speeding
through the empty streets yeah crazy
and then driving around manhattan
because it's it's a wasteland
and i look obviously it's not like a
desolate a post-apocalyptic fallout
you know style you know you know
junkyard or whatever there's people
walking around living their normal lives
but in many ways
it's it's a fraction of what it used to
be to the point where these kids can
ride around their bikes smash windows
and just
there's nothing anyone can do about it
so that's happening now what's going to
happen when
the value of the dollar goes even lower
so this
when there's a whole bunch of unprepared
people that don't have resources that
don't know what to do that don't have a
plan
are stuck without any of the important
things coming in and this is what i'm
saying
if right now in new york teenagers on
bikes can just
attack an suv and you get away with it
and and we see people just driving
around manhattan it's lawlessness
what do you think happens if the police
can't handle what's going on right now
you know ruffian teenagers smash in a
car how do you think they're going to
handle
pockets of 50 to 100 people in different
parts of the city smashing their way
into supermarkets screaming we want to
shop we need food
the cops are going to go i can't do
anything about it sorry if they can't
handle this now
you do not want to be in a city like
that i can't believe there are people
who are staying there too and they
didn't handle it they didn't handle it
in uh
during the summer of this year during
the black lives matter protest when they
were just standing around not doing
anything having their little
uh protest against actually doing their
job
so when it came to when the people
needed them the most when there was
rioting when there was looting when
there was actual violence in the street
they literally just stood back and
watched everything happen yeah they did
nothing
so i think we're getting dangerously
close to that point where
you know i was talking i i'm talking to
my lefty friends trying to explain to
them the problem of mass
printing with what were they nearly
doubled the money supply or a 66
increase that's crazy and uh you know we
did a segment about it and it was
we got a ton of views on it because
people are like they're seeing that
spike in the money stock and they're
like
what does that mean that looks scary
like because you have all of this to
200 years of slow and steady increase
and then straight up
so so but but just wrap up my point real
quick talking to my lefty friend i bring
this up and i'm like
what does that mean for you i don't know
20 for a gallon of milk 15 bucks for a
gallon of gas
at some point right if the money stock
has just doubled
the inflation's coming soon read your
history man read about all these
countries whether where the
hyperinflation happened
and the mass printing of money resulted
in people shoveling bills into the
dumpster
what you were saying so i agree with all
of that and
um this problem definition that we're up
against i mean it's so so first up that
chart
seeing the m1 the money supply just
spike listen keep a journal i mean this
is
crazy times this is the hard part i want
to shake people buy the lapels i want to
slap them
you know airplane style wake up because
this is insane what's happening right
now it's literally insane and if you
can't decode the signal so if this is an
easy signal
66 increase in the money supply trust me
we're going to get people like when's
this inflation going to shop
like it's already here but the inflation
goes where the money goes
so they printed all that money they
mostly gave it to rich people so what
are rich people like they like
jewels art yachts gulf streams
trophy properties stocks and bonds all
of those are through the roof right now
we're seeing all that the pricing on
that if you can even find a lot of this
stuff
so you held up water this is what my
company is a company t-shirt we're all
about resilience and so the problem
definition side is like yeah this stuff
is happening how much convincing do you
need once you're past convincing
what do you do about it yeah you know
that's what we need to be talking about
it's like what do you do about this
because already where i live in western
mass
all the properties got snapped up all
the just a fraction of a percent of
people leaving new york in boston said
that was enough to kill our real estate
market yep thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time